As a filmmaker,
Christopher Nolan always wants to walk a
fine line if there's one fundamental
theme that suffuses his entire
filmography,
it's that cinema as a shared narrative
can be a hugely powerful cultural force.
I'm far from the first to notice for
mentioned that many of his films
reference film itself that,
for example,
the inception team bears a strong
resemblance to a film crew,
but interestingly though,
a lot of his work could be called Meta
cinematic.
Nolan is extremely careful about
avoiding medicine amatic images in his
work.
For example,
in the established Batman Continuity,
Bruce Wayne and his parents are out to
see the mask of Zorro film before the
fateful double murder.
That insights,
the dark nights,
whole saga in Batman begins,
however,
Nolan's retelling of that origin,
the Wayne's are out to the opera
Mephistopheles instead.
That change is a purposeful one.
As Nolan has said in an interview,
we didn't have young Bruce Wayne going
to see zero because it character in a
movie.
Watching a movie is very different than
a character in a comic book watching a
movie,
it creates a deconstructionist thing
that we were trying to avoid.
The reason Nolan tries to avoid this is
because over and above everything,
his cinema has always been about
immersion,
bringing you into a story so fully that
the edges disappear and you're carried
along by the narrative momentum.
This is the line that Nolan wants to
walk.
He wants to be immersive and medicine
and at the same time,
in other words,
he wants to hide in plain sight.
Hiding in plain sight is essentially the
subject matter of Nolan's fifth film and
my favorite,
the prestige.
You could almost call this film Meta,
Meta cinematic,
and that it functions as a kind of rule
book for how to achieve this immersive
effect without seeming
deconstructionist.
To use Nolan's words,
just take the first sequence.
The first thing you see is the film
title over a mysterious shot of several
mislaid top hats in the woods.
The text here is,
of course the title card,
but if you know the film,
you know that this text also has a
literal function because these hats are
the prestige of the prestige itself.
The second clue is in their number
doubles,
copies,
multiplicity.
It's the key to understanding the tricks
of this film,
and this is echoed in the second shot as
well with bird cages of identical
canaries from here,
Michael Caine's character goes onto
describe how a magic trick works.
It'd be magic trick consists of three
poles,
the pledge,
the turn,
and finally the prestige.
The sequence carefully sets up the films
own pledges that is borden and Angie are
played by Christian Bale and Hugh
Jackman respectively while illustrating
it's method through Michael Caine's
voiceover and his trick for the little
girl,
but the film is playing its own tricks
here through editing.
Where is this voiceover coming from?
Usually in film a voiceover mean someone
commenting on the events being shown
from sometime in the future and when the
scene ends,
it cuts to the courtroom scene of
borden's murder trial.
Picking up the last phrase,
as if Michael Caine's whole explanation
was testimony.
It's not until the very end of the film
that we learned that the bird trick with
the girl is chronologically.
The last moment in the film,
Nolan reverses the temporal relationship
between the voiceover and the scene
under it,
and this kind of displacement is the key
mechanism for the whole movie.
The Prestige is all about a trick that
moves its object through time and space
instantaneously.
Well,
this is exactly what all film editing
does.
Most of editing cuts between short
distances and continuous times.
Indeed with a simple cut that's what
most people expect,
but that seems simple.
Cut can traverse great distances also
and great lengths of time in either
direction.
Nolan has described learning the power
of this by watching terrence Malik's,
the thin red line in which Malik cuts to
memories simply without blurs or fades
or wavy lines,
and the powerful effect this can have on
a viewer.
The Prestige exploits this power to the
extreme cutting between multiple
different nested memories.
Nolan sets up this device with board and
an engineer's respective journals,
but once these devices are established,
he cuts between the narratives at will
and without warning.
In this way,
the prestige demonstrates a unique
capacity of film without compromising
the audience's suspended disbelief.
The complex narrative structure is
totally subservient to the story Nolan
wants to tell.
It's necessary to keep its twists secret
until the film wants to reveal them.
This is Christopher Nolan's great gift
as a filmmaker.
He's so intune with the dynamics of film
narrative,
but he can construct a plot with so much
forward momentum that even when he gives
you all the clues,
you remain at his mercy until the very
final shot.
Now,
if this was the only lesson of the
prestige,
I'd be satisfied and calling it a great
film,
but there's one scene here easily missed
that adds a final important point.
I think
it's fine.
You can watch the prestige and enjoy the
story for what it is.
That's what Nolan wants for us.
He wants us to be amazed and as the film
itself says,
most of us want to be fooled,
but all films,
even one as tightly wellmed as this
invite a probing.
I,
as the boy sees into the bird trick we
can see into cinema and we're accustomed
to taking most editing for granted,
but the way stories are told,
the tools of any storytelling medium in
large part determined the way we
construct our own memories,
shared or personal.
This is all to say that studying film
doesn't kill it's magic.
It feeds that magic back
into the real world.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching and thank you again
to squarespace for sponsoring this
video.
I am just really fortunate to have
squarespace helping to fund this channel
like,
like everybody out there who's pledging
on Patrion,
allowing me to put all my energy into
just making new videos,
which is all I want to do and I think
makes for the best possible content and
squarespace is actually really great.
If you don't know,
it's like sleek professional,
intuitive looking websites where you
don't have to know coding to make one
and you can get a free domain if you
sign up for a year,
can start that trial
today@squarespace.com.
It's a free trial and if you use the
offer code nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off of your first
purchase.
Squarespace.
You should.
Thanks guys.
See you next week.